The upcoming Game of Thrones prequel series,
House of the Dragon, is based on George RR
Martin's Targaryen history book Fire & Blood.
House of the Dragon is a Game of Thrones prequel
show that is confirmed by HBO’s president
to air in 2022.
Miguel Sapochnik and Ryan Condal will serve
as showrunners and executive producers. George
R. R. Martin will also serve as executive
producer.
It is based on George RR Martin’s book Fire
And Blood volume 1 and on Martin’s yet unfinished
Fire And Blood volume 2 book.
“Fire & Blood begins their tale with the
legendary Aegon the Conqueror, creator of
the Iron Throne, and goes on to recount the
generations of Targaryens who fought to hold
that iconic seat, all the way up to the civil
war that nearly tore their dynasty apart.”
In other words, it covers events from Aegon's
Conquest to the Dance of the Dragons.
That's Fire And Blood volume 1.
The yet unreleased Fire And Blood volume 2
will continue from where part 1 ended, with
Rhaenyra Targaryen's son Aegon lll's reign
and will cover Blackyre rebellions, war with
Dorne and go all the way to the Mad King and
Robert's Rebellion that ended Targaryen dynasty.
But back to Aegon's Conquest. King Argilac
Durrandon, also known as Argilac the Arrogant,
was the last Storm King from House Durrandon,
the rulers of the Stormlands since Durran
Godsgrief, a legendary figure of the Age of
Heroes and founder of Storm's End, and until
the Conquest by Aegon I Targaryen.
And before we continue I wanna talk for a
moment about fantastic sponsor of today's
video.
The House Durrandon of Storm's End is a former
Great House of Westeros. It ruled over the
Stormlands until the War of Conquest. It also
held much of the Riverlands until they lost
them to House Hoare. The head of House Durrandon
held the title of Storm King. Their houses
words were "Ours Is the Fury“ and their
sigil was a crowned black stag on a gold background.
Sounds familiar? Well, that’s because Aegon
Targaryen’s half-brother, Orys Baratheon,
took the Storm King’s seat, daughter, house
words and sigil for his own House Baratheon.
The title of Storm King was held by an ancient
Durrandon kings, who ruled the Kingdom of
the Storm, most of which is now the Stormlands
and at one point included the Riverlands,
Crownlands and the eastern part of the Reach.
The first of the line was Durran Godsgrief,
the mythic first Storm King and the founder
of House Durrandon. Legend has it that he
was married to Elenei, the daughter of the
sea god and the goddess of the wind, and was
the builder of Storm's End.
The Storm's End's construction was attributed
to Durran, a legendary figure of the Age of
Heroes, who earned the hatred of the sea god
and the wind goddess when he took Elenei,
daughter of the two gods, as his wife. In
rage, the two gods sent massive storms to
destroy Durran's keep. Durran defied the gods
and built a larger and more formidable keep,
but it was also destroyed. Durran's seventh
keep, built allegedly with an aid of Bran
the Builder, withstood the rage of Elenei's
parents and gained the name of Storm's End.
The Storm's End became the seat of the rulers
of Stormlands, the Storm Kings, for millennia.
One of the mightiest fortresses on the entire
continent, Storm's End has endured many sieges,
but has never fallen to any attacker in its
millennia-long history. Its seaward wall is
80 feet thick
with a 150 feet drop into the sea below. The
castle is said to be protected by spells woven
into its walls that prevent magic from penetrating
its defenses. The Storm King during Aegon's
Conquest and therefore the last King of the
Durrandon dynasty was Argilac the Arrogant.
Argilac was a warrior king and considered
to be old by the time of Aegon's Conquest.
When he was a boy, King Argilac turned back
a Dornish invasion. Towards the end of the
Century of Blood, he joined the great alliance
against the tigers from Volantis and led a
host into the Disputed Lands, marching against
an army from Volantis which was attempting
to retake Myr. Twenty years later, in the
Battle of Summerfield , he killed King Garse
VII Gardener of the Reach. Harren the Black,
the King of the Isles and the Rivers, was
nearing completion of his massive castle,
Harrenhal, and was said to be looking for
more conquests. Argilac had grown afraid of
Harren and so he tried to forge an allegiance
with Aegon Targaryen who was at Dragonstone
with his sisters and their 3 large dragons.
It is believed he wanted to create a neutral
area serving to separate hostile forces between
his kingdom and Harren's. The Storm King offered
to Aegon the hand of his maiden daughter,
Argella in marriage as well as dowry lands,
although, much of the lands were in fact in
possession of Harren the Black. Aegon refused,
and instead offered the hand of his best friend
and rumored bastard brother, Orys Baratheon.
Argilac took this as a grave insult and had
the hands of the envoy cut off. He sent them
to Aegon with a message of "These are the
only hands you will receive". Aegon called
his banners and took counsel with them and
his sisters. As Aegon had been waiting for
an excuse to use his armies and dragons on
Westeros, this came in well. Then Aegon sent
ravens to the rulers of the Seven Kingdoms.
He informed them there would only be one king
in Westeros. Those who bent the knee would
keep their lands and titles, but those that
didn't he would destroy. King Argilac refused
to submit. Aegon then strategically placed
himself between the Kingdom of the Isles and
the Rivers and the Kingdom of the Stormlands,
so that Argilac and Harren could not decide
on who should take action against him. After
landing and proclaiming himself Lord of the
Seven Kingdoms, Aegon named Orys Baratheon
the Hand of the King and sent him with a huge
army and his sister Rhaenys on her dragon
to take the Storm's End. Although Orys was
met with some setbacks, he continued to march
on Storm's End. King Argilac refused to be
trapped inside his castle-like King Harren
who was roasted by dragonfire inside his castle
walls, so he came out to meet the invaders.
He attacked Orys's forces while a huge storm
raged, in what became known as the Last Storm
which resulted with the fall of the Kingdom
of the Storm and the foundation of House Baratheon.
Argilac outnumbered Orys's army two-to-one.
As the two armies closed on each other, a
massive storm, that would give a name to the
battle, broke out. Argilac, knowing he had
almost twice as many men as the Targaryens
and four times as many knights and heavy horse,
decided to press the attack. Three charges
by Argilac's horsemen were slowed by mud,
although his spearmen had greater success
on foot and Durrandon host conquered two hills.
During the third charge Argilac broke through,
but encountered Rhaenys atop Meraxes, who
destroyed their attack. By confusion, Argilac
was thrown from his horse and found himself
face to face with Orys Baratheon. Both took
a wound, but soon Argilac would get his wish
and would die fighting, slain by Orys Baratheon.
His death ended the battle, as the stormlanders
yielded or fled. After her father's death,
Princess Argella Durrandon barred Storm's
End and declared herself Storm Queen. Her
garrison, however, feared to share the fate
of Harren and revolted against Argella after
a few days, delivering her to Orys, chained
and naked. Nevertheless, Orys treated her
gently, removing the chains, covering her
with his cloak and giving her food and wine.
Afterward, Orys married Argella and became
Lord Paramount of the Stormlands. He took
the castle, lands, sigil and words of House
Durrandon for his own family, House Baratheon.
Argilac got his nickname for arrogantly refusing
Aegon's offer of marrying Orys (a bastard)
to his daughter, cutting off the hands of
Aegon's envoy and sending them back to him.
He was also arrogant in engaging the Targaryens
in open battle rather than withstanding a
siege in the infamously impregnable castle
of Storm's End. However, Argilac was motivated
in this by having heard of the death of Harren
Hoare in similar circumstances at Harrenhal,
who prepared for a siege in his immense castle
only for the Targaryen dragons to fly right
over the walls and burn him inside. If Argilac
resisted a siege by Orys, it would only be
a matter of time until the Targaryens directed
their dragons to the castle, so wishing to
avoid this fate Argilac met Orys in an open
battle. The last Storm King might have been
a bit arrogant, but he was no coward, but
a true warrior. He's called arrogant for refusing
Aegon's proposal and for fighting Targaryens,
but on the other hand, the King in the North,
Torrhen Stark is called the King Who Kneeled
because he did not fight the Targaryens, but
rather kneeled to Aegon, prioritizing his
people over his ego. So whichever option the
Storm King had chosen, he would have still
had an undesirable nickname and he was a born
warrior, so death by fighting a war was his
best choice. Aegon's Conquest, the Storm King,
King in the North, many epic battles, all
of this is part of Fire And Blood, the long
Targaryen history, and the upcoming Game of
Thrones prequel, House of the Dragon is based
on the Targaryen history. We are bound for
an epic journey starting in 2022 which is
when the first episode of the Game of Thrones
prequel airs. Thank you so much for watching,
if you enjoyed this video please give it a
big thumbs up and I hope to see you in the
next one, peace!